giữa chưa thằng sau, bóa và sư đi giữa giữa trang nằm nếp mình dưới trên đối ở của lý chiều, mắt lưu qua những tấm biểu mục tiêu.
Tôi qua, anh nhìn tình nhận của một phụ nữ đăng là mạnh và sĩ sống ở Trung Quốc nhiều gia tháp vương mộ mũ vì đã lâu cô không về nước.
Mất 20 phút lần tiền, xe ông mời thấy đúng tên mộ.
Chẳng chàng trai người xuống nhổ sẽ cò, quất sợ, lâu mũ, thắp nhàng đốt mọi đẹn dầu dưới dưới đi.
Đây là công việc thương ngày của xưa từ vấn năm năm nay.
Mọi người nói về của anh là giữa đàn, tức là chăm sóc không vình mộ,
với khóa thay cho thân nhân của người đã khóc.
Nhưng anh thay từ gọi người của mình là giúp việc trong người dưới mộ.
Nguyên giữa đàn trẻ tuổi như xưa là chương hoặc xuy nhất ở đàn năm.
Xe ông, 25 tuổi, sống ở của lý chiều,
năm 2019, công ty sản xuất vĩ đẹp xưa phà dài thị đúng thời điểm dịch COVID-19 mũ phát,
nên anh công nhân cho thân người thất nghiệp, chuyển sát là phục buộc, chế bàn tại các nhà hàng.
Tốt thường suyên gặp áp được mời tính cách khóa sự từ đồng nghiệp hoặc khác nhìn bỏ việc khu vô sở đó, anh kể.
Mộ lên đi xin việc không thành, xưa người nghỉ dưới khóc kây, được mộ phương nữ nhờ đồ cát,
giòn mộ mộ lần của chiếc hí sảo chế lia đi cửa.
Anh nhận lời, làm cần tận và được bà trả công năm 2019.
Xe ông thích khá lớn sò với mức lương năm trước đồng mối tháng cuộc công việc chế bàn.
Sau lần tình cửa ý, xưa nhận thể lọng mình chơi tháng thản và bình íên mối khi chăm sóc những người mộ.
Từ đó, người càng nhiều khách tiêm đến anh khi có 2 hách thơi trong một tháng, anh cứ đến có đây là công việc tọn thế giang.
Hàng ngày, cư bộ giờ 8 mi phút sáng anh dậy trình bị chổ, giòn nhàng đèn rồi đến gái trang làm việc.
Lâm sông, xưa ăn sáng, nghỉ chứ và tích tuộc công việc bùi chữ khi chở gì lắm.
Tối đến anh trở lại kinh trà lượng dầu và thắp đệ lần nữa, ngoài ra anh còn xưa li các vết nước,
bong chóc để giữ mộ trong tình trạng tốt.
Nhiệ giữ đàn khiến cuộc đời tôi như sáng trang mới, xưa kinh, không áp lực, không mộn phình, không ai sò sét, không cần trưởng công.
Hàng ngày vừa làm, vừa được nghe chim họp, khi thử khổ phi trong lạnh rất trình đối,
khó khăn gì nhất trong công việc là giữ đèn luôn trảy.
Anh phải càng dở trăm dầu 2 lần mỗi này.
Mỗi người trả xưa vài trong nghìn, tổng tối nhập khoảng năm triệu đồng mũ tháng.
Chưa chi phía nhàng đèn, anh còn khoảng 8 phy nhập triệu.
Thìng khoảng, anh vẫn phủ việc liên quan đến vụ biệt đã để kiếm thêm,
nhưng tôi hành lòng vì sống đủ xưa nói.
Nhiệ cho anh nhiều bài học sống, đối tiên là quy lật phố thường,
có người sáng vẫn còn trở chuyện, chứ người thân đã lý thể lập mũ.
Đưa nay khiến anh chính trọng cuộc sống hơn, đồng thời, anh thấy không việc ý nghĩa,
bởi thân người thân làm điều họ không thể.
Công việc này dân trở thành đam mê của tôi, xưa nói, tôi cảm thấy thình thành bởi mác.
khi đi ngang những hôm họ không ai nhiều cầy, anh vẫn từ vệ giỏi dễ và thấp hơn, không cần được trả công.
Mong muốn mọi người yếu đúng hơn về công việc của mình,
thì thẳng xưa quay video như lần mình đi giữa đèn và đăng lý mạng sở hội.
Bất người là các video khi lại cạnh một trần trời gàn rất là việc trong nghĩa tràng đã thú hút hàng triệu lửa xem.
Tôi tin bất kỳ công việc nào cũng có ra chỉ, mến mình tâm viết, xưa nói.